we've been telling you about the ongoing
shortage of building materials causing
delays and building houses and of course
causing prices then to increase yeah joe
mohler taking a look at this story live
in the southwest valley to tell us how
the current market is impacting buyers
joe
we've been watching the real estate
market here in southern nevada just get
more and more expensive while the
shortage of building supplies isn't
necessarily helping the situation we did
talk to one local real estate agent
about all of this and the outlook on the
market now
we're seeing it happen right now trish
nash is the broker and owner of
signature gallery of homes she says the
average cost of a new home is now 450
thousand dollars that is up 15 percent
from last year from garage doors to
baseboards builders are facing delays
with materials stuck at the port some
people are waiting weeks and months
longer than expected nash says this is
impacting people's interest rates there
was a buyer that had to
do a rate lock three times
spent so far over twenty five hundred
dollars in rate locks the southern
nevada home builders association told us
some builders are asking building
departments to allow people to move in
with simple materials missing multiple
cities told us their building
departments are being impacted the city
of las vegas tells us they are trying to
be flexible with builders because of the
shortage but safety is a top priority
people that are coming here needing
short-term rentals even long-term
rentals
and they can't find it according to
rent.com the average rent for a two
bedroom in the valley is now
1946 dollars that's up 31 percent from
last year we have seen situations where
individuals have chosen not to move here
because they can't find a place to live
nash says if you are looking to buy a
home now or anytime in the near future
it might not be a good idea to wait
because she does not expect interest
rates to stay as low as they are right
now reporting live in the southwest
valley joe muller live local now